who will pursue him now when you
consider that Bill Belichick so quickly
went after Antonio Brown despite
everything that we knew about without
hesitation
Bill Belichick pursued Antonio Brown and
it led to speculation that maybe maybe
Antonio Brown acted a certain way to get
out of Oakland the same way he acted a
certain way to get out of Pittsburgh and
maybe this was an inside job and of
course it's all irrelevant now but the
fact that Bill Belichick was ready to
give this guy safe harbor it's gonna
make another team all it takes is one I
see this all the time
31 teams can shout he'll know about the
prospect of signing a player if one team
whispers yes it's all it takes
Washington they were interested in
trading for toggery kill I was told
earlier this offseason back during
training camp when Trent Williams was
and still is holding out and there was
some thought that maybe they could work
something out and end up with Tyree kill
well now they get a Antonio Brown and do
you look look look look what
Washington's did last year with Rubin
Foster it is what they did with Rubin
Foster worse than what they may do with
Antonio Brown Rubin fostered it had been
arrested Rubin Foster was facing
criminal charges and it all worked out
for Washington I could see Washington
saying hey you've already made nine
million for this year how about we sign
you to a one-year six million dollar
contract and off we go so that's the
first team just because dysfunctional
teams do dysfunctional things and
currently there's no PR director in
Washington because Tony Wiley has left
for the Special Olympics I don't know
that there's a voice of reason right now
to talk Bruce Allen and Dan Snyder out
of being seduced by the talent that
Antonio Brown clearly has so no matter
what anyone else does with Antonio Brown
whether they sign them whether they
don't sudden the league still has an
investigation that is not going anywhere
the league has the prerogative and the
obligation to continue to investigate
and the the lawyers for the second
accuser issued a statement not long
before Antonio Brown was cut by the
Patriots indicating that the league has
made it clear that Brown was told do not
have any further communication with this
individual in the mere fact that the
league
would be responsible for issuing that
mandate tells you the league thinks it's
problematic then Antonio Brown did that
so between the first accuser the second
accuser the allegation of intimidation
of the second accuser Antonio Brown is
looking at an eventual suspension quite
possibly now if you're Washington you
say all right how long is he gonna be
suspended we'll take him on we'll pay
him as he goes if he gets suspended we
don't pay him if he gets put on the
commissioner example let's see that's
the problem
they paid ruben foster last year on the
commissioner exempt list but they
weren't paying him very much
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports